hi I am Kent Hua a Solutions manager for
application modernization with Google
cloud in this video you'll learn more
about the GQ optimization solution which
is an offering that's part of Google's
Cloud application modernization program
or camp
[Music]
in our first video we talked about
Google's Camp a framework designed to
help guide organizations as they adapt
new ways of developing and modernizing
their application ecosystems
one of the key pillars of Camp is build
and operate as cloud computing continues
to evolve organizations are interested
in learning how to build and operate
their applications using the latest
development patterns platform
capabilities and tooling
a key area of interest is
container-based applications Google
kubernetes engine or gke runs kubernetes
the open source container orchestration
platform on a managed cluster of virtual
machines one of the solutions that's
offered as part of Camp is gkey
optimization with this offering our goal
is to help customers continuously
deliver business value by running
reliable performant and cost efficient
applications on gke there are two
different pads that are available within
GQ optimization jumpstart is a great way
if you're just getting started with gke
and want to learn the best practices so
you can start on the right foundation
the first step is understanding what
options are available to you this will
help you figure out how to balance cost
reliability and scaling for your
applications and services
the second step is learning how to
maintain reliability as your application
is scaled up or down automatically by
gke
the third step is monitoring and
enforcing helping your company's
platform and infrastructure teams
monitor resource usage and make sure
everybody is following the company
policies
and fourth there's culture how can your
company kick-start spinops culture to
focus on cost efficiency the other path
to take a look at is assessment this is
for organizations already running on gke
with a data driven engagement we can
help you understand what's running in
your current environment and make tailor
recommendations to help you minimize
costs while maximizing reliability and
performance
there are several key golden signals
that we'll take a look at during the
assessment
Explorer golden signals are divided into
two categories resources and discounts
app developers and platform
administrators are responsible for the
resource optimizations while platform
administrators and budget owners are
responsible for the discount
optimizations
the first signal in the resources
category is workload right sizing this
is all about comparing requested
resources to actual utilization so that
we can make sure we aren't over
visioning our resources
in the second signal is off-peak hours
during times of the day where traffic to
your application is lower your GK
cluster should scale down appropriately
third there's been packing Harold will
take a look at whether or not you're
requesting the appropriate machine type
and properly packing your pods deployed
in your environment
the fourth signal is the discount
section its spot and cut coverage this
metric measures the percent of resources
covered by either spot or preemptable
VMS or committed use discounts
spot VMS can provide up to 91 off from a
budget perspective
one of the key benefits of the GQ
optimization offering is Taylor's
recommendations for your container-based
environment
based on what we understand about your
unique use case we can recommend
personalized adjustments based on these
golden signals if you would like to
learn more about camp and its GK
optimization solution
see the links in the description below
and make sure to watch other videos in
our camp Series where we cover an
overview of the camp program best
practices and tools for containerized
development and modernizing Legacy
applications thanks so much look forward
to seeing what you build
foreign
[Music]